[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
15 septembre 2008 lehman rabat ce défi
ce jour-là financier mondial
en plongeant l'intégralité des économies
européennes et des économies développées
et émergentes dans une crise financière
sans précédent pour nous recensons
encore aujourd'hui et fait 15 septembre
c'est la marque à notre histoire moderne
il marque un but du 10 puisqu'elle
consacre à la faillite de l'une des plus
anciennes institutions financières
internationales human raveurs qui
s'effondrait fait un vulgaire château
car 15,7 en 2008
ce jour-là eu l'effet d'un véritable raz
de l'est dont la vie depuis d'une
vingtaine de milliers de personnes qui
désirent tout ce jour là y compris
monnaie comme les aiment les femmes que
vous venez de voir sur cette vidéo
ce jour là je rentrais également six
mois avec comme seul bagage les cartons
dans lesquels jean fermait des années de
travail acharné mais surtout mes rêves
mes inspirations une certitude de
l'époque
ce jour-là monde s'effondre art je
verrai mes repères presque huit ans jour
pour jour je suis aujourd'hui devant
vous je suis viré crise investissement
dans un fonds de capital investissement
à capitaux internationaux est dédiée au
financement des champions nationaux et
développement économique du continent
si je suis là aujourd'hui devant vous
c'est pour vous dire que c'est possible
et que nous sommes pas la mesure de
notre potentiel
s'il ya une seule chose que vous devez
retenir ton intervention c'est que nous
avons tous en ont le pouvoir de réaliser
nos rêves de réaliser nos aspirations
pour peu que nous y croyons au plus
profond de nous-mêmes qui se fige jeu
philippe élus je suis ici en côte
d'ivoire comme certains d'entre vous
j'ai fait mes études à gujan tout
commença par les études primaires
c'était assez simple puisque cette
époque au fond tout ce qu'on me
demandait c'était d'avoir de bonnes
notes
d'où vient travailler d'être une bonne
élève et d'exceller en tous points dans
tout ce que je faisais donc qui pouvait
pas y avoir plus clair quelque part
comme feuille de route
puis arriva le moment d aider des deux
études secondaires et là je commençais à
me demander de ce que je voulais faire
quand je serai grand par l'homme est il
bien sûr sur la sienne quand ma mère
qu'elle fut pas si les factions lorsque
celle ci répondit mais paris et qui sûr
que tu veux passer sa vie entière
assis derrière un même comptoir à servir
les médicaments oh mon client je suis
sûr que tu te trouvais beaucoup plus
passionnant
la passion être passionné par quelque
chose on sait ça veut vraiment dire il
fallait que je trouve un sujet un thème
une vocation qui puisse me passionner et
que j'en fis faire un jour mon métier je
vous parle d'une époque la côte d'ivoire
est en proie à ses premières difficultés
économiques d'une époque où finalement
le pouvoir
été relégué un stade de mise et où je
prends d'un micro ça sera beaucoup plus
sain je crois est
j'ai donc je vous parle d'une époque où
finalement la côte d'ivoire était était
à la fin de son envolée et de son
miracle économique ivoirien et où le
thème des éléphants blancs d'afrique
était celui qui était utilisée dans les
sphères internationales pour décrire est
montré du doigt notre déclin et celui de
l'intégralité dû continent
puis vient malheureusement le premier
coup d'état
et c'est à ce moment particulier que
comme dans un sentiment de vengeance
j'ai décidé sans nécessairement savoir
comment que j'allais contribué à au
groupe positionnement de mon pays sur la
sphère économique internationale et que
j'avais contribué mois au développement
économique de mon continent
j'avais 18 ans cent jours d'entraînement
comment le faire le bac en poche
et vu que je ne savais pas quelles
étaient les moyens d'arriver à cette
grande ambition
j'ai décidé de me lancer dans la grande
aventure des grandes écoles de commerce
en passant par une classe préparatoire
et c'est là que commence à le début des
grandes difficultés y'avait plupart à
l'isolément l'éloignement le travail
acharné encore et toujours toujours
travailler mais ça n'avait en fait
jamais de fin et vu qu'en fait on avait
appris que dans toutes choses qui font
que je fasse il fallait que je citerai
les responsabilités
un soir fatiguée de travailler fatigue
et de badges ajouté je décide à prendre
mon courage à deux mains et d'appeler ma
mère pour lui dire que j'avais bien
réfléchi et que je j'avais mûrement
réfléchi et que je décidé de rentrer en
côte d'ivoire et d'arrêter la prépa
aucun problème si le pays peut offrir
beaucoup d'opportunités à des jeunes
sans diplômes comme toi tu veux être
technicienne de surface sur la voie
publique
tu peux vendre toutes sortes de produits
au bord de la route
tu peux tu peux même pas de quoi creuser
mais ces scènes parce qu'il te faut un
diplôme et surtout hors de question que
tu sois caissière dans la pharmacie
parce que déjà c'est le fun parce que
c'est plutôt offrir sans diplôme et puis
j'ai jamais pris personne par qu'ils
sont et il ya aucun aucune raison que je
commence par toi mais bon vu que tu as
vraiment réfléchi sa décision que la
bienvenue et l'aviron suis dit que ce
serait vu ses perspectives ce serait
beaucoup plus simple pour moi de rester
dans ma chambre enfermé continue de
bachoter métaireau y théorie économique
pour passer le concours des grandes
écoles de commerce
plutôt que de rentrer au pays et
comprendre c'est pareil de toutes ces
belles l'insecte thiriot portuaire
hockey et donc c'est ainsi qu'après deux
années de travail acharné jeu battre aux
concours des grandes écoles de commerce
et la premier drame de ma vie je n'ai
pas h essais je n'ai pas la deuxième
meilleure école de commerce en cubes je
n'ai pas la troisième meilleure école de
commerce non plus je n'ai que la
quatrième région
le drame de trale de baisse
et soit dit en passant heureusement que
j'ai eu cette école parce que c'est là
que j'ai pu rencontrer mon mari qui lui
étaient ravis d'avoir l'oeil ont acheté
c'était pas ce problème
et honnêtement la vie était très belle
avions donc pourquoi pourquoi demander
tant qu'on te dois voir si peut très
bien attaqué son bonheur à vous et donc
je vais 6 à 4 tienne c'est pas grave je
n'ai pas eu la meilleure école de
commerce mais j'ai décidé que j'allais
avoir le parcours des meilleurs
étudiants et celui de se tacher sais je
vous parle les années de nu c'est le
sacre de la finance internationale
les introductions en bourse des fusions
acquisitions c'est le sacre des banques
d'affaires et donc moi j'ai décidé que
j'allais réussir à intégrer l'une des
meilleures plus grande donc d'affaires
de la scène internationale à cette
époque là il y en avait quatre qui
faisait rêver
goldman sachs lyman graveur merrill
lynch morgan stanley soit dit en passant
aujourd'hui il y en a plus que deux qui
ont survécu la crise et donc après un
processus de sélection très compétitif
c'est ainsi que j'intègre en juin 2006
l'imam raveurs donc ce département a
fusions acquisitions à londres avant
même d'avoir fini mes études et
d'obtenir mon diplôme
j'avais à peine vingt trois ans l'équipe
que je rejoignais à l'époque était l'une
des plus performantes de la scène
financière internationale puisqu'elle
réaliser 40% du volume
les plus grosses transactions en matière
de fusions acquisitions l'époque
quelle ne fut pas ma fierté l'orage et
plus encore lorsque je pu les rejoindre
et quelle ne fut pas ma fierté de
pouvoir travailler avec elle
ce fut un environnement très dur pour
régner le culte de l'absolu excellence
de la charte de la quête infinie de
perfection du travail acharné du
dépassement de soi nous n'avions pas le
droit de voir et nous donne un travail
moyenne de 8 heures à 3 heures du matin
tous les jours ce qu'ils se trompaient
pour rentrer chez eux
à 23h se retrouver totalement surchargé
de travail devant moi qui ne faisaient
plus plus jamais cette erreur c'était ça
le monde voilà de la banque d'affaires
une machine impitoyable qui nous
transformait en automate il nous
réfléchissions plus nous étions
uniquement centré sur laquelle sur cette
pièce de perfection et nous pensons plus
individuellement mais collectivement
mais confond nous étions l'immédiat rien
ne pouvait nous arrêter
rien ne pouvait nous détruire et nous
commencions à prendre des risques
démesurés jusqu'au jusqu'à cet été 2007
ou arriva le premier retournement de
conjoncture et la crise des subprimes
nous refusions d'entendre les premiers
signes d'alerté les personnes qui
essayait de nous de nous alarmer sur
justement ce retournement de conjoncture
et cette existence d'une dette
impressionnable au niveau de cette loi
ces personnes là qui essayez vous
alerter se retrouver relégués à leur
grade et un culte de la finance
internationale qui ne pouvaient pas
comprendre le monde dans lequel nous
vivions et qu'ils ne pouvaient qu'envier
cette espèce de cages lourd et un peu ce
truc tible dans lequel nous évoluons
indescriptible jusqu'à ce vendredi 12
septembre 2008 soit trois jours avant la
great ce jour là les personnes que
j'avais finalement institué en modèle de
réussite de succès c'est donc et
d'affaires qui faisait la pluie et le
beau temps au sein de la place
financière internationale de londres
ces requins comme on les appelait
s'effondrait sous les yeux parce il
réalisé qu'ils avaient tout perdu leur
passé leur présent leur futur dans un
tonneau me peut-être même le raison
d'aden je me souviendrai toujours de
l'un mais directeur qui était le plus
performant en fait de nos 20 ans
qui nous a tous appris dans son bureau
qui a sorti une boîte de tequila en
bouteille de tequila qui nous a dit les
enfants du vent c'est la fin du vol un
autre succès est là lorsque je le
regardais s'effondrer et noyer son
chagrin et sa pauvre tristesse dans une
pauvre petite bouteille de tequila je me
rendais compte que ce que j'avais
institué en modèle de réussite ce qui
pour moi était finalement le graal du
grac grave
ce navire insubmersible dans lequel nous
avions tous évolué pendant toutes ces
années était en train de couler comme un
vulgaire titanic et que moi je coulais
avec lui
15 septembre 2008 s'effondre que vont
devenir la golden girl n'est plus l'imam
rabat n'est plus je n'ai plus de raison
d'années est donc là avance une violente
période d'introspection de remise en
question au fond que voulait que vous
voulez qu'est ce que je voulais vraiment
être qu'elle était mais raph quelles
étaient mes aspirations que juge de vue
et suis fier de ce que je suis venu et
là j'entends dit la petite fille qui
avait grandi au bord et la levée des au
bord de la lagune ébrié et à qui ses
parents avaient toujours dit quel que
soit ce que tu fais il faut que tu
fasses avec passion parce que c'est la
passion qui déterminera d'un succès me
souffler à l'oreille tu nous as oublié
tu m'a oublié tu fais oublier
et là j'ai décidé plutôt que de baisser
les bras et de et de succomber face à
cet échec de prendre mon courage à deux
mains et de faire de cet échec
les moteurs de mon second succès en tout
cas les moteurs d'une saison réussie et
donc j'ai décidé de renouer avec la
vocation première qui était celle de
contrer
au développement économique de nos pays
au fond c'était ça la vocation première
est donc j'ai identifié les principales
institutions qui était très actif dans
le financement du secteur privé sur le
continent africain
et c'est comme ça que je suis allé taper
à la porte de proparco filiale allemande
française de développement et entités
qui est la plus active dans le
financement du secteur tribu en afrique
francophone
je vais raconter mon histoire et je leur
ai dit vous avez pour ambition de
développer le continent
j'ai pour vocation et ambition de
participer à l'envol de mon continent
prenez moi parce que vous ne pouvez pas
vous ne trouverez pas mieux motiver que
moi pour remplir cette mission
et c'est comme ça que j'ai intégré les
équipes banques et marchés financiers
proparco et ça a été une révélation
ça a été l'une des plus belles
expériences de ma vie parce que je
redécouvrais non seulement mon
africanité
mais je parlerai le continent du nord
[Musique]
et l'afrique entre les opportunités
d'entrepreneurs de la jeune afrique et
les institutions financières de la ville
d'europe et c'est ce que j'ai fait et de
rencontres en rencontres
j'ai décidé d'accepter donc la
proposition de la direction général de
proparco qui partait pour fonder à
beauxis finances est donc aujourd'hui je
suis directrice dans ce fonds et je peux
dire que oui j'avais réalisé mon rêve
puisque j'ai contribué
sur ces huit dernières années aux
financements dont plus d'une vingtaine
d'entrepreneurs depuis une vingtaine de
sociétés financières et entreprises pour
des montants en euros d'une centaine de
millions de dollars
voilà
et oui il est bien précisé si c'était
pas du tout c'était bozic lokoka banque
d'affaires mais la gold ailleurs se
retrouve beaucoup plus à l'aise dans son
pays en côte d'ivoire où j'ai même
contribué également à créer un fonds
d'investissement accord produit ici en
côte d'ivoire née visite à rennais
l'épargné locale pour la réinvestir dans
le tissu économique du pays de la
faillite est désolant c'était sa
vocation
enfin j'ai réussi et vous quelles sont
vos ambitions quels sont vos rêves
quels sont vos inspirations parce que
voyez vous nous aurons tous des craintes
des doutes des peurs qui nous engagerons
d'aller jusqu'au bout de nous mêmes
comme disait notamment de la drôme où
les sims 3 c'est bon m sur 10 tonnes je
me suis sam cela paraîtra toujours
impossible jusqu'à ce que nous fassions
et c'est ce que je suis venu vous dire
aujourd'hui au fond nous avons tous en
nous un potentiel qui ne demande qu'à
attribuer
nous avons tous points monde et trompe
qui demande à être rayés l'envolée des
lucioles lorsque les organisateurs des
ténèbres
on en avait participé à cette édition je
me suis interrogé sur le le thème et sur
son sens c'est vrai que c'est très beau
évolution' ça symbolise le succès la
consécration d'un réussissent mais
attention
l'éruption est mort après alors en veut
donc que suis je venu vous dire qu'on
prenne une opiniâtreté à devenir les
papillons qui porteront l'envol de notre
continent de demain réaliser vos rêves
réalisés dès expiration
soyons la quatrième génération que le
monde adam 12 pour porter l'envol et le
développement économique de notre
continent
soyez le changement que vous voulez voir
pour le monde pour notre continent et
par lettre contient yes we can
[Applaudissements]